alors lui dit en fait on est tous des
robots en fait il suffit de voir les
gens s'arrêter au feu rouge
tout le monde fait la même chose toute
la journée quoi payer
nous avons dit d'entrée on rentre on dit
sortir ouais ça c'est vrai tu fait qu'on
nous dise un truc qu'on le fasse on est
des robots de chair et de sang mais des
robots quand même quoi
ben c'est pas incompatible - oui
puis on et moi j'essaye d'être un robot
j'ai fait le disque les machines mais je
me suis aperçu qu'au fond ce n'est pas
du tout kraft joueurs compris que
c'était plutôt l'humain qui revenait au
galop
ouais je me suis fait pas d'ailleurs
c'est ce que j'attendais au final on est
tous conditionnés par les numéros oui
enfin conditionné je sais pas il ya des
histoires d'amour il commence très vite
avec des numéros de vin donne moi ton
temps portable amber c'est tout c'est
des fois c'est le premier mot de
l'histoire d'amour et après ces deux
mois tu un numéro de carte bleue
ça peut être les derniers
il se sent que j'aime bien c'est l'album
c'est celle qui est consacré 11
septembre
parce que c'est qu'est ce que tu faisais
le 11 septembre sans fête où tu étais le
sort de la coupe du monde c'est à dire
qu'en fait les gens c'est une façon de
se rassurer
parce que finalement ils ont une
histoire individuelle face aux grands
événements du monde quoi quand il quand
il ya des avions qui s'écrasent dans les
tours moi je suis en train de manger un
sandwich sur un ben ouais
et pourtant ça se passe au même moment
des anciens tu dis le 11 septembre juste
en train de manger un sandwich sur un
banc oui voilà sur en même temps un but
chaque fois sans indiscrétion
au port un ben ali ni un panini saumon
le pire elle s'appelle bien l'ambiance
un peu ils se sont tus et poursuivie par
marine le pen et tu dis que c'est une
histoire vraie ouais ça s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé à la maison de la
radio doit être invité à une émission
politique où chaque fois et puis c'est
vrai je suis j'ai suivi une fille blonde
et s'est retournée c'était l'horreur
oui tu as un truc sur marine le pen tu
dis finalement c'est un être humain quoi
c'est ma soeur je suis ta supérieur même
si je suis pas d'accord avec ses
opinions politiques
je me suis posé la question dans un
c'est vrai si j'étais invité un mariage
où il ya marine le pen qui est invité
aussi sait-on jamais arrivé elle propose
une partie de ping pong qu'est ce que tu
fais je sais c'est un canal sur scène
être humain bien sûr ouais
après il faut gagner quoi c'est ça
l'important lui met la péter
mais
voilà maintenant c'est que tu veux pas
en fait se sentir supérieur tu dis par
exemple quand on chante on ou paul loup
sulitzer tu dis après tout qui vais pour
pour critiquer paul loup sulitzer quoi
ouais après tout c'est vrai c'est vrai
au fond c'est vrai et c'est vrai qu'elle
chantait marine le pen ces cétacés
enfin c'est pas un truc très glamour
enregistrés dans l'axé c'est pas des
mots que tu as envie de prononcer dans
une chanson c'est l'idée de faire une
chanson vilaine au fond avec des choses
vilaine qui peuvent ensuite tu supporte
pas quand calogero chante tiananmen tu
dis ça me donne des frissons dans le dos
quoi c'est parce que le mec s'est trouvé
devant les chars s'étaient pas lui quoi
encore c'est sûr et c'est de cela
capable et c'est probablement le
document ouais je sais pas si j'ai pas
pourquoi il fait ça pour passer pour ce
mec je sais pas mais
moi ça me déprime apple vous savez moi
je la garde parce qu'il n'a pas bonifié
j'adore ou alors tu as fait un film
aussi peau de cochon c'est quoi alors à
contenu alors ce film c
c'est un film que j'ai fait tout seul
mais enfin c'est à dire je me suis
occupé des la lumière des décors j'étais
chef opérateur avec une petite démo
attend rythme quoi un film extrêmement
laon qui peut s'accompagner le
de haricots verts et sec et chaud le
conseil est essayé je suis 3 4 fois ses
films le conseil avec du sable chaud
c'est excellent un samedi soir tout le
monde en parle
je crois que c'est une solution de repli
non comment la lna les familles helena
noguerra comment va-t-elle très bien
elle vient de voir ici régulièrement
voilà désolé quand on te parle d'elle
c'est la moindre des choses c'est comme
ludivine sagnier
comment comment elle va alors très bien
j'ai dîné avec les tout à l'heure était
en excellente état de forme est ce que l
t'excite où elle te dégoûte c'est très
sympa je gérais paraît évident